dichtes gedränge auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
in lissabon die portugiesen lassen sich
die vorfreude auf die festtage nicht
nehmen in diesem jahr dürfen die buden
wieder öffnen dank masken pflicht und
corona pass korrekt zu der frau
eintreten für
mehr verkauft ginger der kirchenchor
gilt als portugals alternative
dieses fest tut den menschen hier in
lissabon gut und das ist auch gut für
den handel und für uns händler
es hält unsere gemüter
der 64 jährige hatte im vergangenen
winter enorme einbußen auch sein café in
der innenstadt war dicht dass sie nun
wieder so ausgelassen beisammen sein
können liegt an der hohen impfquote im
land mit fast 90 prozent eine der
höchsten in europa
der impfstoff wird nicht verhindern dass
wir uns qualifizieren das wissen wir
mittlerweile an
aber wenn wir uns infizieren sind wir
geimpft viel stärker geschützt als um
geld und portugal beugt mit verschärften
coroner regeln weiter vor einreise und
zugang zu vielen öffentlichen
einrichtungen sind seit anfang dezember
nur noch mit impfung und negativ test
möglich mit einem mega impfzentrum auf
dem messegelände öffnet sich das land
für den winter bis zu 6000 menschen
können hier am tag ihre dosis bekommen
dutzende aushilfen wurden eingestellt
studierende junge arbeitslose wie martha
almeida bei dem job geht es der
gelernten erzieherin um mehr als ums
geldverdienen als
die impf kampagne gestartet ist spielte
für mich nicht nur die tatsache eine
rolle dass ich irgendeine arbeit brauche
ich halte es für eine wertvolle arbeit
um dem land in dieser phase in der wir
stecken zu helfen so kann ich etwas
nützliches beitragen
nämlich den wettlauf gegen die zeit
gewinnen vor allem die älteren zu
versorgen bevor deren schutz nachlässt
die dritte impfung ist jetzt besonders
wichtig wegen dieser neuen variante
die krankenschwester paul ag hat heute
ihren freien tag geopfert um ihre
kollegen im zentrum zu unterstützen ich
bin seit acht uhr morgens hier und habe
diesen vormittag schon 30 impfungen
verabreicht
ich habe eine große familie zwei kinder
vier enkelkinder deshalb will ich muss
schützen mich und meine familie
dass die portugiesen im kampf gegen
korona auf gemeinsinn setzen bekommen
wir immer wieder zu hören oft leben
mehrere generationen unter einem dach
beim impfen geht es nicht nur um den
eigenen schutz es geht um den schutz der
anderen
für mich war es im letzten jahr sehr
schlimm ich hatte mich mit kuwait
angesteckt das war eine schwere
komplizierte zeit für uns alle
niemand wusste damit umzugehen und wie
wir die krise überwinden
anfang des jahres wurde portugal
besonders heftig von der pandemie
getroffen das gesundheitssystem
kollabierte die bundeswehr kam mit
medizinischer hilfe erst ein strenger
lockdown ausgangssperren
schulschließungen home office pflicht
konnten schließlich die zahlen senken
doch der schock wirkt bis heute und
macht eine gesetzliche impfpflicht
überflüssig sie werden noch nicht einmal
diskutiert erklärt uns der virologe
petrus es gebe so gut wie keine
impfgegner
gehört zu den ländern mit der höchsten
todesrate gemessen an der einwohnerzahl
die langen warteschlangen der
rettungswagen vor den krankenhäusern
haben eindruck hinterlassen und mündeten
in einer vom militär streng
durchorganisierten im kampf konnte
[Musik]
und so impfte portugal im sommer so
viele menschen wie kein anderes land in
der eu wäre und ihre großmutter anna
stevic genießen jeden moment der
freiheit den sie dadurch zurückbekommen
haben
der impfstoff ist eine großartige sache
zum beispiel dass die diskotheken wieder
aufgemacht haben ich hätte nie gedacht
dass das überhaupt noch mal passiert
aber jetzt haben sie wieder geöffnet
wäre hat gerade abi gemacht unter
erschwerten bedingungen zwei schuljahre
in folge fiel der unterricht für mehrere
monate aus nun machen sie sich sorgen
angesichts der steigenden incidents mit
mehr als 200 so hoch wie lange nicht
doch immer noch deutlich niedriger als
etwa in deutschland
wir hoffen dass die infektion nicht
hochschnellen und dass wir weihnachten
relativ normal feiern können und unser
leben weitergeht ohne lockte ohne dass
wieder alles schließt
sie seien corona müde erklärt die
kinderärztin einer stevic aber
keinesfalls info.de das liege auch in
der geschichte portugals begründet erst
in den 1970 er nach der revolution wurde
in dem land ein staatliches
gesundheitssystem eingeführt die
kindersterblichkeit war damals sehr hoch
und viele erinnern sich noch an diese
zeit
fast alle eltern stellen diese frage
nach dem impfen wenn sie mit ihren
kindern bald aber auch so rufen sie an
um mich zu fragen was ich denke meiner
meinung nach sollten auch kinder geimpft
werden
portugals gesundheitsbehörde hat gerade
die impfung für kinder ab fünf jahren
freigegeben
es gibt historisch bedingt generell ein
großes vertrauen in medizinische
einrichtungen und gesundheitsbehörden
wir wissenschaftler haben von beginn an
mit den medien eng zusammengearbeitet
und die vorteile von impfungen in
zeitungen und im fernsehen erklärt
und viele länder schauen neidisch auf
die hohe impfrate portugals und die
disziplin mit der sie hier maßnahmen
befolgen die jetzt in der adventszeit
noch einmal verschärft wurden um
weihnachten das beisammensein zu
ermöglichen
die familie hat einen sehr großen wert
besonders in dieser weihnachtszeit eine
sehr portugiesische tradition die die
familie rund um den tisch versammelt
portugal hat gelernt sich vor der
pandemie zu schützen mit vorsicht gehen
sie nun durch die wintermonate bereits
jetzt wurde eine woche der zurückhaltung
in der kontakte eingeschränkt werden
müssen für die zeit nach weihnachten
angeordnet
[Musik]